all right yesterday I told you that
President Joe Biden has announced he
will be seeking re-election in 2024 this
of course did not go unnoticed by the
failed former president Donald Trump who
seeks to be his party's nominee in 2024
and would in theory face off against Joe
Biden assuming Joe Biden wins the
Democratic primary Donald Trump
massively massively triggered having a
completely insane reaction starting a
four-minute statement with many of his
typical Grievances and talking points
about Joe Biden let's look at the
beginning of this reaction then we'll
look at some key moments and uh then we
will talk about Donald Trump being
scared to debate seemingly now and
flipping out over debates being
scheduled without his approval let's
first start with the beginning of
Trump's reaction better Lighting in this
video I will admit to Joe Biden's
announcement you could take the five
worst Presidents in American history and
put them together and they would not
have done the damage Joe Biden has done
to our nation in just a few short Years
to everybody who believes that I
challenge you to present data
data not conjecture I challenge you to
present data showing the damage Joe
Biden has done not even close
thanks to Joe Biden's socialist spending
Calamity American families are being
decimated by the worst inflation in half
a century banks are failing our currency
is crashing and the dollar will soon no
longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat in
over 200 years none of that is true
there's just none of it is true real
wages have been falling 24 months in a
row
in other words under Biden workers have
gotten a pay cut each and every month
for two straight years understand that
real inflation-adjusted wages
also fell during periods of Trump's
presidency it's not a completely unique
thing
we have surrendered our energy
we have not okay so I'm in a positive we
have not surrendered energy Independence
we're producing more oil than than we're
exporting more oil than we import it's
it's crazy what's going on here okay so
Trump just trotting out his standard
lives but then he got very apocalyptic
and he teased that Moore Biden will mean
World War III now remember
Trump's been predicting World War III if
Hillary were to have gotten elected in
2016 he's been predicting World War III
during Biden's first term hasn't
happened he's just always predicting
world war three but then he really
unleashes on Joe Biden they say Trump
was right about everything well
I'm not predicting World War III but I
will say this we're very close and
they're only talking about nuclear
weapons on top of it all Biden is the
most corrupt president in American
history absolutely no evidence of that
and that's not even close nobody can
believe what's going on with again no
retribution whatsoever with such a
calamitous and failed presidency it is
almost inconceivable that Biden would
even think of running for re-election
you know what happened in the last
election yeah Biden won they cheated and
they rigged the election
so in all honesty my friends
does anyone really expect Trump to be
saying anything different it's been lies
about the Biden Administration from day
one it's been lies about the 2020
election from day one what else does
Trump have what can Trump Retreat to
there is nothing there and so this is
what we're going to see and by the way
continuing with the transphobia saying
children are being mutilated
our children are being indoctrinated and
mutilated by left-wing Freaks and
zealots I'm struggling to believe that
that is actually what is going on and of
course it isn't expect a lot of this and
Donald Trump is now in a tizzy partially
because a guy named Ron DeSantis didn't
rule out running against Trump and may
announce his campaign and that
infuriates Trump because it's not a sign
of loyalty and I'll be honest to some
degree the reason Trump is triggered
about Biden running again is
Biden beat him in 2020
and Trump no matter what he says
publicly knows if he beat me in 2020 he
could beat me again and the question for
Trump is given that he lost in 2020
how can he gain ground on Joe Biden in
2024 Trump's arrest and indictment May
well help him with Republican voters
it's not helping him in the general
election and so the mathematical problem
for Trump is you look at the map and you
look at the results of 2020 then you say
well you know a lot of these states
Arizona certainly hasn't moved to the
right since 2020 Wisconsin hasn't moved
to the right since 2020. Florida has but
Trump won Florida so that doesn't get
him any additional electoral votes so
Trump realizes it's a difficult map and
whether you believe Trump believes it
was stolen or not
Trump knows if you replicate 2020 in 24
it doesn't look particularly good for
Trump and so Trump is scared and the
other thing he seems scared about is
debating let's talk about that next
by now all of us know how creepy it is
to talk to a friend about something and
then get ads that are related when you
use a free email service from a big Tech
Corporation your emails are scanned even
if you're emailing your spouse or your
doctor which is why I recommend start
mail the email service that never scans
or analyzes your email our sponsor start
mail also lets you create unlimited
email address aliases so you don't even
have to give out your real email address
this protects you from spam and phishing
attacks phishing attacks are becoming
way more sophisticated with the rise of
chat GPT by the way start mail lets you
encrypt any email you send even if the
recipient isn't using encryption unlike
the big Tech email Services who store
even your deleted emails when you delete
an email in start mail it is gone
migrating from your current email
service to start mail is just a few
clicks so what are you waiting for stop
letting big Tech corporations spy on
your email my audience gets 50 off your
first year at startmail.com Pacman the
link is down below